فانها يعني تشبه حال البلاد الزينه
متواضعه جدا وبسيطه خنقت يعني خنقتها ازمه
الكهرباء ولكن يعني
البهجه في قلوب الناس الذين ينتظرون على
مدار العام هذا الشهر الفضيل رينا رغم رنا
اليوم ونحن نتابع معك جديد الاخبار من
لبنان حول وضع رمضان في رغم الظروف
المعيشيه والاقتصاديه الصعبه الى اننا لا
يمكن ان نتجاوز الجانب الاحتفالي مظاهر
الاحتفالات بدخول الشهر الفضيل على
اللبنانيين اليوم هل من جديد فيما يتعلق
بمبادرات المغتربين مثلا
نعم المبادرات يعني في لبنان على مدار
العام بسبب هذه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه الصعبه
والتعاضد الاجتماعي ياخذ اشكالا كثيره الا
ان يعني اموال المغتربين وخاصه في هذه في
هذه الفتره يعني يعول عليها المغتربين
اللبنانيين في افريقيا وفي اوروبا وفي
الدول العربيه يرسلون اموالا الى الجمعيات
التي تعنى بتوزيع حصص غذائيه ووجبات
للافطارات هناك ايضا يعني مبادرات محليه
انا قمت بجوله في المدينه القديمه قبل ان
اتي الى هنا يعني طبعا الناس كلهم
استوقفون للقول كم عن غلاء اسعار الخضار
والفاكهه والسلع الشراعيه الشرائيه ولكن
هناك سيده قالت لانه على الرغم من كل ذلك
هناك بركه في النفوس يعني قالت ان الخضرجي
قدم لها اليوم بعض الحبات من الفاكهه
واخبرني اخرون ان هناك شخص تكفل على نفقته
الخاصه باناره كل شوارع المدينه القديمه
واحيائها الشعبيه اذا يعني المبادرات لم
تعد خلفيه على احد والمغتربون هم ايضا
يعني لم يعد خفيا انه عليهم عول
اللبنانيون وبفضلهم يمكن
صمد اللبنانيون لفتره طويله خلال هذه
الازمه